the tub I think sci-fi films in my
estimation would be 2001 for sure or
probably for that as number one we the
start of the film was how the ship is
actually driven by a computer that's the
first he was even humorous he defused
his brain we ended up singing Daisy
Daisy give me your answer dudeney I they
asked right and then I think George
Lucas's Star was the one he did output
that is number two then I do there in
Blade Runner I'm not gonna be modest
about that I think we got a really right
Blade Runner which is a in a ways of
problem because Blade Runner has been a
very strong influence on lots of other
films which is nice it's amusing but
it's boring you got to move on you got
to move forward right it's hard to move
forward because I think I landed first
on real dystopia and then everything
else is a variation on dystopia but
they're watching films start to get made
I thought were quite good when I was in
my teens the Y thought was really good
was more about the Cold War with Gregory
Peck and it was called on the beach with
Ava Gardner and it's the end of the
atomic war and the only area left
ironically is Australia that's good swim
to get very good beautiful black away
movie it's when they're really original
which would he counts a jump forward
quantum leap forward